each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay well it's a great pleasure to
welcome partha ranganathan partha got
his PhD at Rice University and he's
currently a principal research scientist
at HP Labs parts has been doing work on
computer architecture and parallel
processing and as you'll see in this
talk has been looking a lot at issues
around performance power and
manageability parth is also leading a
new project called blades plus plus at
HP Labs investigating next generation
system architecture for enterprise
environments and so if you're if you get
a chance to talk to him you can talk a
little bit about that anyway it's a
great pleasure to welcome partha and i
just want to mention his schedule
there's still some time in a schedule
this afternoon so if you if you wanted
to spend some time talking to him we can
probably arrange it so just calculate op
ok sounds good ok so well the title kind
of talks about itself and as been
mentioned my group looks at a couple of
different things one is the smart power
project where we look at power
management across the spectrum of
devices all the way from handhelds to
data centers and then the place plus the
project and today what I really want to
do is to focus more on the smart power
project and even there basically the
agenda is kind of out here so what I
really want to do is to this pointer is
pretty faint here so what I really want
to do is to talk a little bit about what
is the power management challenge what
are the problems we are trying to solve
and I'm going to focus on two specific
solutions in great detail and then I'm
going to try and give you a sense of
some of the other work and hopefully if
I have time I'll kind of talk about our
efforts and tying this all things
together and in kind of some of the work
we have done in tax on amazing various
approaches and so on ok so let's think
about why is power in part and I put up
a couple of cartoons well there's one
and then there's your data center
blowing up but more importantly I mean
these things give you your funny
punchline but what's interesting is I
both of these cartoons were formed from
a quick web search shop I won't tell you
which is search company I used but
they're quick web search looking for the
terms data center
were and then it's kind of funny when
when you have things in the public
domain in the popular cartoon strips
about power management and the point
basically power management is
increasingly a bottleneck irrespective
of whether you look at processors
servers supercomputers data centers or
whether you look at the mobile market
the handheld market the data center
market enterprise market and so when we
start thinking about why is probably
important we tend to think about it
along to access the first one is the
average power axis and they're basically
the key point is how much electricity do
you consume and so if you think about
mobile devices pretty much everyone here
has had problems with recharging things
and and so this is obviously going to
get worse with convergence and smaller
form factor so this particular thing
basically has a whole bunch of
functionality and I always keep wanting
more and as I start adding more and more
stuff the battery life gets to be pretty
interesting and so that's obviously an
important issue but what's interesting
is for tether devices the electricity
cost of getting to be an important issue
as well and San Francisco Chronicle had
an article about Google's datacenter
power and that was running in the
hundreds of millions of dollars per year
and then so this gets to be pretty
interesting very soon and then there's
the second aspect of power consumption
which is the environmental friendliness
and so this is basically numbers 22
million gigajoules 4 million tons of
carbon dioxide this is just for the
annual annual consumption for
computation just in the US alone and
then obviously that's getting to be a
big issue in fact I am in I'm in
conversation with the do II where they
are basically looking at an Energy Star
rating for servers and we have been
helping influence what that may click
ought to be and and it's always funny
when people try to legalize
interestingly silly things so scale I'm
sorry I'm from the handheld space but a
thousand racks is that a common data
center or their thousands of those in
the US or this the thousand axis
basically if you look at articles data
center in Austin for example that that's
so thousand access pretty large but it
depends on also what you have in your
racks and this is assuming eight
kilowatt back then and you'll get a
sense of this as we go along so
some and so again Google Google article
actually I was down at Microsoft data
center back back locally here as well
and and so these are all kind of good
sized data centers but it's going to be
a problem in just 50 or whether you have
a departmental data center or enterprise
data center there you go you got the
data find right there so do the map
there and he's just at 28 million no but
anyway so the second axis of power is
basically the peak power and so when we
talk about peak cover this is basically
thermal issues and a lot of time
especially in the enterprise environment
this is what people worry about
basically the power delivery the
packaging and cooling and then so if you
look at various data here I'm just going
to focus on this particular set of
pictures here the blue line is let's
focus on the red line that's the energy
consumed by your servers and the blue
green line is the energy in the air
conditioners and the takeaway point is
as you go to the higher end for every
watt of power you consume in your
servers you wouldn't need an additional
wat or even sometimes an additional
couple of watts to extract the heat here
so going back to the Google Data Center
100 million dollar in server electricity
two hundred million dollars in the air
conditioner direct city so it's kind of
a vicious cycle in itself and then
there's a whole bunch of temperature
noise issues this is particularly
important for our European customers
where they vary more about noise but
doctors are getting to be important
everywhere else as well and finally
there's a whole bunch of soft matrix
matrix like compaction density and
reliability so if you think about dense
blade servers for example thermal issues
get to be increasingly interesting the
liability most people know that when the
temperature goes over a certain point
things are going to shut off but what is
also interesting is that when you
operate your server for example if you
operate at more than 10 degree Celsius
over the default operational temperature
it's been documented this is actually
data from uptime Institute that you have
a 50-percent degradation in your
reliability and same thing with hard
disks and so on so basically they're
going to be a lot of soft issues in
terms of peak power and so on so well
then the obvious question is well power
management and the associated problems
are really not new there's been tons of
work done there so and this is basically
kind of a quick
summary of all the work that's gone on
here I'm not going to go into more
detail actually teacher Corps guest
course on power management at Stanford
and this takes a whole quarter so my
goal is not to kind of give you a
tutorial on what's been done but the
point is to emphasize that people are
basically looked at it at the circuits
level at the architecture level at the
operating system level application level
so there's tons of work done so the
logical question as well why the heck
are you working on it right so let's
kind of take a step back and look at
what are the goals that we want and
there's actually a very interesting
paper from IBM and if anyone is
interested in power management that's a
very classic paper I'd encourage you to
read and it kind of talks about the holy
grail of mobile computing which is human
powered variable computing and it
actually talks about energy sources from
as silly things like body heat to things
like walking and so on but even if you
aren't worried about this let's look at
solar powered and and so if you look at
solar powered and this is for California
not Seattle so you mean quite a bit of
Sun pure and even there you basically
look at the amount of power that you can
generate it's an order of millibars and
you look at a typical handheld or a
typical laptop essentially what you're
looking at is you need a huge amount of
improvement and where we are to where we
want to go and so the Holy Grail is
quite a bit far away same thing that if
you look at header devices so this is
actually a picture from a keynote
thought that was given about blade
servers maybe a year a couple of years
back and what it talks about is this is
your typical traditional server rack and
it says somewhere about 8 kilowatts but
as you kind of go to more denser servers
and more blade servers you're looking at
easily about 55 kilowatts per rack so
that's almost a factor of 10 increase
from six kilowatts to 60 kilowatts and
so essentially if this continues if you
look at the amount of cooling that you
need in terms of BTU per hour you're now
coming to a place where you are
literally talking about liquid cooling
in the data center so that's kind of
getting to be a problem and this is
actually a picture from from our
conversations with several customers and
what each of these stars are is actually
a customer data center going back to
what you were asking about what is a
customer data center so you have the
size of the data center here and you can
see that there's a whole spectrum of
sizes here and you have the density of
later
enters here in terms of what per square
foot and the point to take away from
this picture there's a whole bunch of
interesting data here is that most of
current customers are operating
somewhere around this range and there's
a few people here who operate around
five kilowatts per rack and and there
are some people including their solid
experimental data centered our lab data
center here that operate around 10 to 20
kilowatts per rack here but when you're
talking about 55 kilowatts per rack
you're going to get a lot of pushback
from customers about the infrastructure
needed to support that and so this is
getting to be an interesting problem and
so and this is basically just
summarizing both of that and it says
essentially you need once again orders
of magnitude improvement putting that
much in a single breath have you been it
instead of spraying that out among
multiple racks which cuz i'm looking at
your chart there in the wash per square
foot and i'm building a lab in 250
watches for a foot I'm allocating 20
square feet uh-huh a rack at 250 watt
square foot you're up in that top range
yeah and so you're looking at probably
50 to 60 square feet per rack to get
those kind of densities so what's the
benefit of having a single rack with
55kw in it instead of having 10 racks
with 5 KW a very good question so
basically if the density is killing us
in terms of what the facilities guys are
telling us so why the heck are the IT
guys going towards more and more density
and there's a couple of trends and i'm
not actually spending a lot of time on
that but if you look at one of the
trends I know Microsoft several people
are worried about is a multi-core
processor so basically if you look at
the fact that Moore's law gives you more
and more transistors you're starting to
put more and more stuff on your single
socket so there's going to be a lot of
compaction at that level and if you look
at processor power budget they are kind
of going up to loo the second thing with
blade servers why do people like blade
servers when you can get a lot of things
similarly functional with rack mounted
servers the interesting issues has to do
with the manageability so if I were to
draw a pie chart of all the costs in the
data center the biggest chunk of that
pie chart has to do with the operational
aspects of managing a data center and
and so by being able to compact things
into a blade form factor where I reduce
cabling that I provide a single unified
management attraction it dramatically
reduces the cost and so people are
willing to come pay a little bit more in
terms of pins and so that's kind of the
tension you're going to have compaction
because of the technology trends because
of the operational trends and then
you're going to have some pushback
because of the power and thermal density
trends and ideally if I'm able to solve
that and I promise 10x at the end of the
talk basically then you can start
facilitating some of this so any other
questions here okay so the question
basically is there anything to be done
and obviously I wouldn't be here if
there wasn't and so that's kind of
thought so what we do at the smart power
project at HP Labs is to systematically
understand the power management problem
and later on maybe if I have time I'll
kind of talk about some of the
interesting taxonomy that come from the
systematic analysis and there's a whole
host of solutions that we have of which
I'm going to focus on a few and even
though I'm going to focus on the more
visible parts in some respect the power
of air system and solution design
there's a lot of work that we have done
under power measurement monitoring kind
of the pumping but this is actually
there's a lot of innovation that went in
in terms of understanding the tools the
metrics the benchmark the frameworks and
again I'm not going to have time to do
go into that but I'll try and give you
guys a sense of that if anyone who's
interested in following up okay so and
since I intend to leave this slide deck
with you guys and since I intend to also
kind of cover high-level goals what I
did was to put together a bunch of lists
of papers that you could look at and so
the first one has to do with
energy-aware user interfaces that using
display and communication power and it
looks like i have an older version of
the slide deck here so the the best
paper to look at is an i triple e
computer cover feature that came up in
march of this year and that has a very
good summary of what we do so so let's
start thinking about energy-aware user
interfaces right so I kind of pointed to
this handheld that I had and if you look
at the key sources of battery power
consumption the display the processor
the violets are probably the three most
dominant and the display power takes up
quite a bit of power if you look at the
battery life I have data here with phase
fifty to sixty percent but depending on
the system you can have anywhere from
thirty to seventy percent and then so
previous approaches to turning off the
display power have predominantly focused
on turning off the entire display so you
have 50 screensavers that come in and
blank the screen when you most want to
use it or you could essentially buy a
laptop for example with
13 inch display if you are a road
warrior and that gives you more longer
battery lights and so on and so when we
started this research our goal was well
both are really not quite good so can I
do something better and so we came up
with this notion of energy adaptive this
place and the fundamental idea is fairly
simple it's basically can I come up with
a display subsystem where the display
public consumption was matched to the
screen content for the user of the past
or the idea is basically given what the
user is using can I match my energy to
exactly expend energy just on what's
going on at that point and so there's a
couple of challenges there one having to
do with first understanding how do
people typically use their screens and
then the hardware and software design
and when we are talking about this place
we are now actually mucking around with
the user interface aspects of the
interaction and so we want to make sure
that we do it in a way that the user
experience doesn't get compromised and I
will talk about that as well okay so
let's first focus on understanding
screen usage and so what I have here is
basically a picture from a user study
that we conducted of 20 different users
and what I have on the x-axis here is
the percentage of screen area used and
on the y-axis is the cumulative number
of samples so the way to lead this is
each graph is one user let's focus on
this solid line which is the average and
so what this says is fifty percent of
the time on average less than forty five
percent of actually the other way so
about forty five percent of the time on
average less than fifty percent of the
screen areas used so the point is on
average across all our different users
less than about sixty percent of the
total screen area was used and this is
just the size of the screen but if you
look at color resolution a refresh rate
in general all the full functionality of
the display was not being used all the
time but if you look at your display
power consumption in most displays it's
one big solid flat line right so I see a
couple of people with laptops here and I
and I'm willing to bet that if you were
to go look at what they're doing their
laptops they're probably using Microsoft
Word white screen white background black
text and they're probably using if you
look at the actual pixels that they are
using it's going to be a much smaller
fraction I think him smiling so at least
have one person doing that
yeah so but anyway so and so we have a
whole paper which talks about why this
happens and it has to go back with the
content the user cares about and how
they want to do stuff there and so that
kind of the goal here question if you I
think you're right that color is
essentially never that that essential
but try giving away a black and white
laptop shuttle of the black of my
desktop sure so the point is again
that's the whole point that's why I
called it energy adaptive this place can
I have the low power of a black and
white display but still be able to
promise color functionality when the
user needs it and you'll find that
exactly what we do here so you'll notice
that there is a black and white screen
here but it is actually a color screen
here so the point again is to be able to
selectively turn off properties of
individual pixels in terms of brightness
in terms of color emissive nurse and a
whole bunch of other itself and be able
to do it from a power point of view so
in terms of our prototype but we focus
mainly on organic light-emitting diodes
OLED displays and all let's have this
nice property where you have a power
consumption based on the pixel value and
different colors have different top
power consumptions and so on and they
are kind of starting to get there it
says expected in handhelds 2006 and I
believe there is a handheld that's
actually in in product ization which
uses hand helps some and then there's
the software aspect which is basically
once you have a hardware display screen
which can control your power how do I
now control it in software and that
basically means so you want to have user
interfaces where you selectively turn
off portions here and this is a very
silly example where this Emacs window is
your window of focus and you kind of dim
the background darken the background
make the background black and white and
the last cases where you actually go to
greens kale and it actually turns out
for the particular older chemistry we
were looking at green scale was actually
more energy-efficient a color
combination than the rest of the stuff
and I'm so the point here with this
picture is just to show that this all
works and so here's a typical user chase
based on the user study that I talked
about this shows your window of focus
and how it varies and this shows your
power consumption and your ello line is
basically with your base LCD bear it it
actually varies about one-half percent
or so here and then you actually have
the solid blue line where you can see
that the power consumption now actually
tracks
what the user is doing with the screen
and so the idea basically is if the user
needs color you kind of go to one of the
spikes and if the user needs something
else you go to one of the troughs here
ok ok so so the question basically as
well that was kind of a simple proof of
concept and we said well all of this
works let's kind of start thinking about
more complicated user interfaces yeah
just switch to sort of highlight one day
you're going on yeah you're telling you
to be there this time on maybe you're
going to that's why we have fancy flash
demos here ok so so kind up again so
it's been just absolutely right that was
kind of a very simple proof of concept
exercise and there is a whole bunch of
science to how do you do it and not
annoy people right we have all seen
paper clips that wake up and tell us to
do things at the least opportune times
so and so this is kind of the simplest
one is basically whenever you have a
window of focus you kind of dim the
screen that's fairly straightforward
that's the example I talked about let's
look at this is a pocket pc or outlook
that's the same outlook screen that you
see on your thing all of this is flash
so we didn't muck around with the source
code for fear of contamination right so
but the point basically is so so this is
your default of pocket pc screen it's
hard to see what we are talking about
here but there's a small battery icon
that says two hours and that's kind of
the power consumption for the displace
here and so the idea is basically you
start leading portions of the screen and
you can kind of been push through the
screen and we basically have a user
interface that kind of does that at the
level of individual messages so that's
one option so another option when I
forgot to mention that if you look at
the battery icon ok I guess if you look
at the battery icon you go from two
hours in my screen it says five hours so
a factor of three improvement there so
if you look at acrobat reader so this is
basically you can read something display
or you can kind of start dimming
portions of the screen and read things
this way so the idea is basically you
have a moving window of light that
tracks what you're doing now this is
where it gets interesting just hang on
for a second so this is where it gets
interesting is we basically now start
conducting user tests where we hired an
external agency they pick people up the
street and then had these user tests
where they said would you like would you
like an interface where you read
something this way or would you like to
read something this way right and
what ended up happening was ninety-five
percent of our users responded saying
that they would prefer this new
interface over the old interface and
this was even before we told them that
you just have a factor of four
improvement in your battery life right
and so that was very strange to us and
we said why is that the case and a lot
of people came back saying well you know
it's kind of emphasizing the area we
care about one person actually mentioned
it's kind of like a bookmark I can kind
of talk to someone else and come back
and figure out where I left off and so
on but the meta trend here was that Levi
de-emphasizing portions of the screen to
save power from a battery life
perspective and the users ended up
thinking that we were emphasizing areas
that they cared about from a user
interface point of view and of course we
tell people that was the goal all along
right but but the point again as now
when we to show people the new user
interface and tell them about the
battery life benefit it's pretty much a
no-brainer to kind of start thinking
about this notion of energy-aware user
interfaces and then the final example is
a Windows Media Player the battery icon
says two of us here so you went into
something that's more green literally
and that's six hours and so the
interesting part is if you look at what
we have here I actually have like a
graphic equalizer I actually have like
the information about the facts as
compared to the old one so I actually
have more information in the new screen
but what I have done is I have turned
off a lot of the pixels I've used
energy-efficient colors and so on and
that gives me a battery life of six
hours this is my screen saver and it
looks pretty awful with the projector
resolution bedrock I have a demo on my
hand held that you guys can see if you
want and so that you can see that the
battery life is about 40 hours or so so
I'm basically the point is you've
essentially turned off all the pixels
focused on the content the user cares
about the buttons and things of that
kind and so you can actually go quite a
bit there and so again and I just have
the usual screensavers come up after 30
seconds just to illustrate the point
that that one loses content you can get
a lot of the power savings without
really losing content so there's a whole
bunch of things you can do with this
thing so I kind of talked about the
spatial and temporal and again we have a
couple of papers illustrating how you
can design user interfaces so so there's
again in my demo there's a bunch of
interfaces that did not work as film so
this is research so we got to show some
negative with us as well and one of my
most favorite things that
work was this amazing incredible
shrinking window and so we had this
window where if the user did not use it
for a while it would become smaller and
smaller and for some reason nobody
really like that so but anyway the point
is again you can kind of think about a
whole bunch of things and this actually
gives you more screenshots and it talks
about the ones with high acceptance up
medium acceptance and low acceptance and
one thing we found was that making the
screen completely dark was unacceptable
several people mentioned that it made
them powerful they can dot it was really
dark for their taste and so on and so
one of so there's a lot of takeaways
there and again the like been pointed
out the science is basically in the
insights that go into codifying the
energyaware user interfaces and we have
actually one of the artifacts that came
out of this work is a set of energy
aware design guidelines so the idea is
basically if you were to have it energy
compliant as certified by HP if the
developers were to follow a certain set
of guidelines we could kind of give them
pretty good guarantees that the users
would like it and it would also save
some benefits and there's a bunch of
intuitive and interesting things there
so that's kind of the bottom line you
can actually save anywhere from a factor
of 2 to 20 in terms of the display power
and the user acceptance was quite high
and it has sub qualifiers on when it was
high and when it was low and what was
very interesting was that for the first
time we actually now have something
that's a win then where you basically
can reduce the energy and have better
user interfaces as well and that was in
some respects the most surprising
conclusion that we really hadn't
anticipated when we went into this study
very briefly just kind of some of the
follow-on things here we looked at very
simple design rules and again they'll
certified here on a frugal grayness
little color rule but you can kind of
extend this in several interesting ways
and then a common question I get asked
as well this assumed Oh LEDs which is an
emissive display doesn't have a
backlight what happens if you have an
LCD display with a single backlight
that's taking up all the power and so we
actually had a solution that works for
that as well and it is a little bit more
challenging but you could think about
hybrid back lights where you have seven
back lights that illuminate it in
several interesting grace and there's a
bunch of things you could do there but
another interesting thing that I really
like is
notion of having multiple display so
basically divide your screen up into a
high power high color hi everything
high-energy display and a low power low
color low everything display and and so
that idea is just as we had insights on
how do you selectively dim portions of
the screen you can pretty much translate
all those insights it's a little bit
harder but we've done that in terms of
how you can actually selectively use
these to display and still not
compromise user interfaces and this gets
very interesting when you're thinking
about laptops for example where you can
start imagining the small task bear
alert bar kind of things and so on so
there's a whole bunch of work there and
finally I talked about content and I
talked about adapting the energy based
on the content you could go one step
further and start thinking about the
intent and start thinking about adapting
energy based on the intent and that's
the whole idea behind these multimodal
interfaces where in the first case you
said well you have you have mail as a
notification can I dim all the white
portions or can I put that in a smaller
low power display but essentially the
intent is main notification and you
could do that very well with a blinking
LED light there and so you and that's
100 times lower power than anything that
you have with the display power and so
on and so you can start thinking about
more energy efficient alternatives
looking at the intent of the
communication there I had a question
there so I have a modulation of the only
answer compass is an analog or false
with so we actually worked with Kodak on
their own lip stuff and I believe we had
drivers that were more at let me think
about this so we basically had an OLED
display panel they change the driver so
actually I don't know so all I know is
they change the drivers and I don't know
enough about if it was am longing is
simply save a lot of error there okay so
but again I think the key is we actually
have a prototype in the lab which I
didn't bring in because it's it's got
wires and everything running out and but
the point is we work with Kodak got an
OLED display panel they just had to
change their devices circuitry so it
might actually be analog I don't know so
and they change their devices circuitry
and then we change the deform there and
the UI layer on top of that and then be
measured the power and so the numbers i
have are very closely matched with what
we got there slice some cds you want to
get me to deletion peer review the
finest aversion so all of this place for
your back five years back they were the
next big thing and i believe they still
are so so but the point is that they
have made quite a bit of enjoyed and
several other domains that we expected
them to so usually when i first gave
this talk for years back i had this
adopt the adoption roadmap and we talked
about car displays and small cell phones
and handhelds and laptops and it was
very clear that laptops was kind of
quite a bit in the future and it's still
this but the list of the load map has
been working out pretty well and so you
see a lot of all at this place but the
problem is LCDs are also improving but
the point is what we've talked about the
notion of energy adaptive displays our
energy adaptive user interfaces are just
it we used all that's because it was the
simplest way to demonstrate it but you
could pretty much get all these benefits
using any display technology you just
have to work harder to understand how to
provide that activity so so that's an
interesting question but not quite
directly tied in with what we're talking
about yes sir going to give pink after
now you believe it's bogus you believe
like a white one seller why
so many medicines our doesn't really
matter again we have looked at this
place and all the stuff and they come up
with a bunch of interesting things they
start off with a fairly low power base
so then the motivation I talked about
with this place taking seventy percent
of the power is not as prevalent there
but again if you want to use some of
these techniques on top of that we have
several patents which talk about how do
you use the bistable II displays all
those kind of things and basically there
you have to kind of follow a CMOS like
model and you have to optimize
transitions as optimizing individual
pixels and so again the concept is
similar the algorithms get changed quite
a bit but really as I said same answer
has been interesting question but not
related to the point I'm trying to make
here and again i'm not a display expert
so i'm not going to get into that
religion because i have talked enough
display guys to realize that it's a lot
of what's the thing kind of looms
whatever okay any other questions you
mentioned is really quickly before what
the three biggest power consumers were
guys you should display I think said
processor lose the other one wireless
wireless so again rule of thumb it
really changes because you have just a
whole spectrum of devices I mean if you
have something like an iPod with more
storage and stuff like that that gets
into the picture as well but again for
typical cell phone and held those kind
of things okay so talking about wireless
so basically this notion of adaptivity
based on what the user wants can be
extended in a very straightforward
manner to wireless and we have a whole
paper on this I'm not going to go into
detail here but the idea is if you look
at 802 11 and if you look at the
wireless power ninety percent of the
power is spent in your idle mode and a
big chunk of that idle mode power is
spent in these power spikes where you
are listening listening for the beacons
right and right now the 802 11 protocol
says this to be 100 milliseconds and and
so this idea was that elective least a
forward one where we basically said can
be exposed the higher-level application
requirements down to the physical layer
so for example i have this particular
device right now right now if i had 802
11 it's still going to be communicating
and every hundred milliseconds can it
realize that the 1d major application
that i probably care about now the email
and kanuk adaptively scale that beacon
interval so from 100 milliseconds to say
one second to say one minute and by
doing that reduce the frequency of
spikes there and it turns out that you
could do that and you could get ninety
percent savings in power but just I mean
it's just a simple matter but the point
again is that when we did these user
tests leave we had people having email
written without this optimization turned
on and we had people kind of blindfolded
and say pick the one that you think has
the energy optimization turned on and
one minute one second delays an email
it's in the noise most people can live
without email for a minute or so and
then so and I knew I was going to get
trouble there but the better point is
basically as long as you have user
experience issues tighten that what they
expect from the application this thing
is reasonable one minute Deacon is
if your access one buffer that much to
write this is the power save mode you
can't just sleep for one minute pen
after paper actually talks into more
detail on how all of this works but the
key point to leverage is that you could
turn your phone off and the whole system
still works so I mean the whole protocol
is set up to drop things the loose stuff
so but it gets into more trickier user
interface issues when you think start
thinking about how your buffers and so
on perfectly valid so location that
would work with such a highly deciding
correct but again now if you go to the
paper one of the things we talked about
is so if you look at the workloads email
phone calls SMS conference saying yeah
there is a whole category of booklets so
again at the end of the day it goes back
to what are the use cases that you think
are going to be dominant right and there
is a whole class of devices where the
use cases have to do with listening fair
enough if I'm going to use my ipaq as I
saw as kind of an mp3 player why listen
to email then again remember I mentioned
what we are doing is to expose the high
level application requirements as
included in all the subset of
applications that you're running and so
if i have a mp3 player that are
streaming audio live from from some
other service provided elsewhere
obviously this isn't the right solution
right so the state-of-the-art erm
broadcom for wireless LAN is wireless
LAN stand by listing access point right
now every hundred milliseconds is lower
power than gsm it's absolutely
phenomenal how good these guys have
gotten these things so you got a nokia
phone out there today they can listen to
gsm and an access point for 125 hours
continuous fair enough ya know okay so
let me quickly switch tracks yours over
hbu you're at eleven five so i have 25
minutes and probably 50 more sly so i'm
going to kind of accelerate somebody
mentioned that they could listen to
twice as much speed without too much
trouble here so so but anyway so it feel
free to interrupt because i tend to
speak faster as i warm up so when things
might get really fast here but so let's
kind of shift back a little bit and
start looking at power of air blade
designs i gave you one example of
average power on mobile devices i'm
going to give you an example of peak
power on enterprise systems and so this
is we had a paper at this car
a couple of months back which describes
this in greater detail and we have a
couple more papers as well so we call it
the dense and smart architecture goes
back to what you need to be smart about
how dense you get your great servers and
it also makes for a funny tagline when
people get it sometimes so the point
again is to look at the enclosure level
power management you have an enclosure
of about many blade servers and we want
to reduce the peak power of this
enclosure and and the key insight here
is that if you look at current systems
they are designed for the peak
utilization of an individual server and
what Leda did differently was to
basically look at an adaptive enclosure
level solution where the power budget
was done enforced was in power budget
was in post and software but the key
idea was to focus on the long-term usage
and look at the entire solution and
again I'm going to talk about how this
has some pretty dramatic potential for
publish savings so let me motivate what
I meant by that right so this is
basically a picture of CPU utilization
on a single server this is actually data
from one of the Apache servers on hp.com
so this is our own local server I have
time on the x-axis I have the average
cpu utilization on the y-axis and I
believe these were taken at either one
second or five-second intervals I forget
what and so the point basically is that
the utilization has all the periodicity
that we are used expecting but the the
actual peak is dramatically different
from the nameplate peak so you end up
with about 75% precure as expected
hundred and the average utilization is
quite a bit lower so now when you look
at the ensemble or the collection of
systems this is eight servers from HP
com and so what I have here is basically
the three web server of the three
application servers in the two database
servers and what I have here is a new
picture which basically again time is on
the x-axis but on the y-axis I
accumulate the utilization of all these
eight servers so each point here
represents the sum of the corresponding
points from decayed servers okay so the
point here is basically what I
summarized here if you were to look at
the sum of the Keeks and compared it to
the peak of the sums there's a pretty
dramatic difference so what does that
mean if you look at this picture given
that you
have eight servers you would expect the
utilization to be about eight hundred
percent that's your nameplate
utilization and that corresponds to your
nameplate power provisioning as well so
that's 800 the actual peak is close to
300 so that's almost a factor of two and
a half different already there and the
actual average utilization is only about
150 so that's almost a factor of 76 are
changed from the nameplate power and
that is very interesting and that has to
do with the fact that you have bursty
workloads and you have non synchronized
burstiness across systems and obviously
this notion across systems is very
critical because what we are really
looking at is leveraging a statistically
large sample of systems where the
burstiness can be your spread up so if
you have two servers both from cnn.com
and both of them go to spike at the same
time that's not obviously not the right
model here but if you have a cnn.com
server and you have a I don't know
Morgan Stanley calm and then they have
some differing patterns there that's
kind of the things we are looking at
here so an answer I kind of just gave
you data from hit be calm but in the
paper we actually talked about nine
different enterprise sites for a total
of about 100-200 servers and again the
net difference between your some of
peaks and the average of your peak of
Suns is pretty darn high here so
anywhere from twenty five to ninety
percent so what does this mean what this
means is this whole notion of compounded
in efficiencies so the way we look at
managing power is we always look at the
power budget for individual peaks so you
would essentially design your blade for
your maximum nameplate power so that say
20 watts and so if you had 20 watts in
the blades you would kind of multiply
them add some extra overhead for your
enclosure that's a 500 watt blade and
then you would have 500 watt enclosure
you put five four of them 10 of them
whatever in one rack and then you have a
10 kilowatt rack and so what ends up
happening is the provisioning
over-provisioning gets compounded at
each level and remember what I showed in
the earlier picture about the cooling
costs increasing as well and so
essentially now you have cooling for
this you have over-provisioning in the
cooling further so we have
over-provisioning in the cooling for
this and kind of start adding up so in
the approach that we are talking about
we want to manage power budget for the
ensemble and we want to manage
budget for the typical case so we could
continue to use to 20 watt blades but
you would now provision the enclosure
for 250 watts and you would publish in
your racks for about 4 kilowatt and I'm
going to argue and i'm going to show you
that this actually saves you quite a bit
of cooling costs and as far as the end
user experience is concerned whether
it's in performance and all the other
matrix here looking at it's nearly not
going to change that and i'm going to
use these 89 real la enterprise
workloads to prove that point questions
logical servlet of multiple boxes was to
stop one rack melting but while the
other rack is freezing because one is
that there's a pica room there's a
trough so let me get to the data center
and talk about that in a minute so
that's not going to happen first of all
first of all all of these things even
though we talked about managing cooling
budget everything is going to have a
plan B which is there's going to be a
thermal sensor and things are going to
shut down so hopefully nothing will melt
unlike dell laptops which explode right
okay so so here's your functional
architecture so the idea is basically
you have hardware software coordination
for power control so you essentially
have your individual systems each system
has a set of support for monitoring
power and controlling power and then
this is where it gets critical you have
a management agent I've shown it as a
centralized box but you could
essentially have it be a distributed box
and what it does is it measures monitors
and predicts the power and then it looks
at all the individual blades and then in
the event that the total power is going
to exceed your threshold then it uses
some kind of policy driven control to
throttle individual blades so if the
idea doesn't make sense think of it as
essentially a budget management across a
group of people it is essentially the
same thing you don't kind of give
everyone their maximum you kind of have
a budget across the group and then you
kind of move these sources dynamically
there and sometimes you use isolated and
not priority to when scheduling of
resources and so on and that's
essentially what we're doing here so we
actually built a prototype blade where
we are evaluated and this is that
picture of that and so the idea is
basically this is your blade and the
areas in green are where we need some
support at the hardware level we need
some support at the CPU to throttle
power because you basically are saying
if anybody exceeds power budget I need a
weight
bring it down and then we needed some
support at the enclosure controller
predominantly in terms of the firmware
we needed to have some extra monitoring
to monitor the power and then we
exchanged the information through sm
boss the blade management controller
talk to the IAM controller over the ice
co XE bus and the usual stuff so when
you start thinking about the
implementation there's a bunch of open
questions the first one having to do
with what is the power budget that we
choose what's the value that we need to
have there's a very interesting question
about the enforcement strictness and
this has to do with whether are you
provisioning the power from a power
delivery point of view which basically
means there's a fuse that blows if the
current exceeds that particular thing in
which case you want to be very strict
about it or are you provisioning from a
thermal point of view which basically
means that you are allowed a few
occasional fancy and Static CD of power
budget as long as you guarantee that
your heat doesn't exceed that so and so
that actually makes life a little bit
easier because you have the lacs
enforcement constraints and then finally
in terms of the power monitoring and
control should you be monitoring power
or temperature should you be monitoring
the individual components the YouTube
polling interrupts aw how do you tie it
back with P States the usual kind of
stuff and then finally in terms of the
policy space there's a whole bunch of
policies how do you assign power budgets
and there's two broad categories that
I'm going to focus on one is called
preemptive and other is called the
active and then so reactive is fairly
straightforward you let every server
spend its power budget and then there's
an enclosure which adds up all of those
and if it turns out that you violate
your total then you kind of go back and
knock people on the head and say you
throttle your power and so on so
basically the nice thing with the
reactive system is you basically use as
much as you want until told you cannot
and I'm so the idea is you're always
guaranteed one violation before you
bring down the power but the good news
is basically that you you don't really
compromise performance because you can
be pretty aggressive the preemptive is
the other option where you basically
need to ask before you can use more
power every blade the distress with the
central guy and the central guide those
out a certain power budget on and the
individual guys are guaranteed not to
exceed that power budget and then if you
need more you come back and ask more and
so on and so the nice thing with
preemptive is you're guaranteed never
take
your power budget but you have the
overhead of having to go ask before you
do that and so there is some extra
conservativeness in terms of the
performance assumptions so finally
there's a bunch of other choices what
service do you throttle and when do you
unsaddle them what policy is to use
their what level do you throttle them to
so we have multiple p States so how many
people here know of these states okay
bout five so P states are basically
defined by a standard called a CPI and
just think of them as multiple power
performance states for now and and so
another idea is basically you can go
from the highest performance highest
power skate all the way to the lowest
performance lowest power skate or you
could kind of look at intermediate
points and then so do you do it
incrementally or do you do it really
deep so there's a bunch of open
questions there and finally asked with
any other huge estate you have the sauce
estimation and polling and how often do
you do that and there's a whole bunch of
things you can do there so they're
cranking them where you ask before you
use more power you know kung foo
before really complex logic is pleasure
they always start off with the most
conservative thing so basically remember
in the picture I showed you that there
is changes in your blade firmware and
there's actually a lot of post post
power-on self-test stuff that we do and
so there's also the that is easy but the
more interesting thing is what happens
if the controller dies and then how do
these blades all go to their respective
stuff so there's a whole bunch of logic
around heartbeat shaking and so for
those kind of eventually go to very
conservative assumptions still the water
and figure out a new checker but really
high pitch gauge exactly and that's why
we need that firmware support because
you really you could run Windows or or
you could run something else and so we
need to kind of make sure that this
happens at a level that we control and
we can guarantee otherwise like he
pointed out we will have things melting
and we really don't want them to yes sir
patience in this scheme actually doesn't
save our just saves the provisioning
power so that what we are trying to do
is throttle the peak remember again
that's why I mentioned what I'm trying
to give you a flavor for both the
average and the peak power and how they
differ but you're absolutely like so and
as far as the details about the power-on
self-test the booty hot beat the paper
has a lot more details so you can look
at that and if you can't find it send me
mail I should be located at ok so a
quick evaluation so we actually built a
prototype we use transmitter blades
because that actually has support for P
states which are across the space and
then we made the changes for the power
monitoring we ran a bunch of different
benchmarks so we played all our
enterprise workloads that's easy and
then we ran some real work loads as well
and we measured power and performance
and there's a bunch of trade-offs in
terms of the various models here we also
built a pretty elaborate simulator which
also makes for some very nice demos that
I may not have time to go into bat top
and so simulator we actually looked at
about 70 different metrics evaluating
all sorts of possible / blade some
summaries or enclosure summaries / blade
some reviewing peak and so on so as you
as I go through the results you're going
to have questions and I'm going to
invoke some of those anyway so the high
levels ourselves basically here are our
these are simulation results here about
nine Enterprise sites this the enclosure
was rated at 500 watts we brought the
provisioning down to 400 425 450 so
anywhere from about ten to twenty
percent savings and so this is the loss
in performance and so essentially you
can see that the loss and performance is
zero in the reactive case and then close
to about one to five percent in the
preemptive case so the point is you can
bring down your power budget by twenty
percent without really compromising
anything there so why is this this low
the main point is at the 1d hook we had
four power control is the processor and
that is actually at anywhere from
twenty-five to fifty percent and so we
actually bring down the processor quite
a bit it's just that if you look at the
blaze that we have the processor is
about fifty percent of the total power
memory actually takes quite a bit and we
didn't have support for memory power
states in this particular prototype but
you could very well start thinking about
doing the same thing for me
as well and and and then there's an
enclosure level of motivation as well so
the point again is marginal impact on
performance and again this was kind of
interested because the preemptive is
actually quite competitive to reactive
and we didn't really anticipate that
when we started doing these experiments
and it turned out basically you could as
long as the communication overhead
wasn't too bad and you did that fast
enough it's not such a big deal yes sir
that last question those really kind of
important isn't that the cost of running
a data centers really the power I
consumed the power of provisions well
guess I'll know because if you over
provision those power supplies are
running inefficiently at you know if you
get the power supplies typically our
most efficient when they're running at
ninety percent of their capacity 9250
the over provision and you run those
things down there consuming more energy
in the park so you there is an energy
savings by habit but an alternative is
suppose I could get twice as many CPUs
that were slower versus half as many
that are faster there might be much
larger safe there okay so two ways to
answer this question right one is the
way that he answered it which is
basically even though it's a
provisioning issue the provisioning also
determines your effects and in fact
there is a data center in San Francisco
that I went to and I said what happens
if you turn ninety percent of your
servers ninety percent of your servers
are turned off without their Idol what
would happen to your electricity costs
because he was writing about how big his
electricity costs where and then he
mentioned the electricity costs would go
down by only about twenty percent and it
turns out in exactly what he said which
is you bring down the servers but you
now operate your power supply at a very
inefficient point in this efficiency
curve and the power supply ends up
wasting more energy so there's a there's
an issue with provisioning from an
efficiency of operational point
perspective which is kind of second
order effect going back to the first
question that you asked we actually have
a pretty elaborate equation if you go to
my website there is a tech report on the
on the tseebo model for a data center
and if you look at the total cost of a
data center there is the capex cost
which is the provisioning how much power
supply the provision how much power
supply to you how much cooling do you
provision and so on and
there is the optics cap which is the
average power and and the Catholics
costs are also quite big especially when
you go to denser and denser blade
servers you're looking at 55 kilowatt
lakhs or 80 kilo watt racks which is
unheard of and you start thinking about
the Catholics provisioning to cool those
things you're starting to think about
the liquid cooling so HP has a solution
called modular cooling which is
essentially to liquid cooled side racks
on top of your music and and so there's
a whole bunch of elaborate solutions
each of which comes with costs and if I
can provide guarantees that your peak
power will not exceed a certain point
you can pretty dramatically reduce the
cap X cos as well so think capex and
opex and your question basically
translates to his capex cost a
significant fraction of total cost and
the answer is essence in those cases
right still don't sound convinced he'll
come back to you in a minute film okay
so so this was basically just are the
utilization traces from the past we had
all the various others there so the goal
was fine the point again is these where
we played utilization traces but one
would argue what happens to deal
workloads so this is actually a desktop
application basically being played back
in back in servers so kind of like the
consolidated client infrastructure the
sun's a servers and the point was
basically the goal was just looking at
throughput doesn't really help you if
during your most critical point you
ended up throttling so for example with
the desktop users I click on and Windows
Explorer icon and if it takes 10 seconds
to pop up instead of one second that is
not very nice and you could still get
good throughput but you could use you
kind of messed up in the most important
areas and so this is actually a VNC
desktop playback and what these two
lines which almost overlap with each
other are the normalized response times
for the various events so basically the
VNC play is a benchmark suite from
Stanford and it measures the response
time from a user event like a click or a
keyboard to when the actual thing
happened and the point again is that our
algorithms are pretty sensitive to these
kind of things and you can actually not
screw up too much we did a whole bunch
of sensitivity experiments and the point
again is the benefits from this approach
depend a lot on concurrency so if you
have all the workloads going a hundred
percent utilization all the time this
isn't the right the right approach for
you and this picture just a little if
that I have a simulator demo that I'm
not going to go into and one of the
things that are that's interesting yes I
talked about top he crowd provisioning
but there's a bunch of other interesting
benefits as well and one of the things I
talked about is if even though we look
at an enclosure there's cascading
benefits beyond the enclosure at the
back at the data center level and so on
the second interesting aspect is this
approach for the first time now makes
the power budget happen at the software
level and that's very interesting for a
bunch of reasons so let me give you an
example right so if you're looking at
designing a 500 watt enclosure the
beyblade designers would do it right now
when that's the baby do it as well it's
basically you take your 500 watt you
kind of divided by twenty blades and you
say well each blade is going to be 20 25
watts and then you take an individual
blade and you say well that means my
processor power budget is going to be 15
watts and then you go to intel or AMD
and ask for a 15 watt power budget and
usually what Intel does is so they're
going to look at their bins and they're
going to say 15 watt just falls into the
low power them and we're going to need
to use ultra low voltage technology so
I'm going to charge you an X percent
premium over something that would have
been much more cheaper if you are asked
for a 17 what that thing right but the
nice thing with being able to do the
power budget at the software level is
basically that you don't need to worry
about those anymore so i can still
design a 25 watt blade but i can have
like a 17 wat processor because i know n
for sleep our budget and software and
that gets to be very interesting because
i have some very interesting cost
dynamics to that like I talked about so
again I don't have time to go into this
in detail but you actually think about
it it's going to get clearer the other
nice thing is now I can vary this power
budget on the fly so for instance this
ties in with some of the other
optimizations I'm going to talk about if
I have data center cooling that i can
redirect on the fly i can adaptively
very the power budget and some very
interesting base and actually so suppose
you have a peak power budget and and
somebody moved a huge amount of cooling
into your data center for two days i can
actually make my power budget higher and
get some performance boost and so on so
that's very interesting and then finally
the same approach can be used for
average power
as well and then we can talk about that
so the point is basically if you look at
geek power in ensemble level by being
able to look at a collection of systems
and being able to manage the power at a
software level across the common case
instead of this usually their name flav
cases you can get quite a bit of power
savings and as before you need some
intelligent heuristics to make sure that
this doesn't get out of control and so
if you read our paper we can talk more
about what this stuff ok so it's 1130
now so I'm guessing I'm between people
and lunch so I'm not going to be
offended if people leave i'm just going
to continue going through that i have
probably about 10 minutes more of
material and so what i really want to do
is to quickly tie it in with some of the
other contributions there so one of the
pieces of work we did this to look at
heterogeneity and so the idea behind
heterogeneity I believe Rakesh was here
and he gave a talk so this is work done
with rakesh for his thesis and the idea
was basically you have a multi-core
architecture what happens when you have
a symmetric multi-course and this was
proposed in 2003 and the industry since
moved to adopt a symmetry in some
interesting ways Intel AMD and IBM have
all kind of expressed interest in having
these things and the point was that we
showed that hydrogenous multicores can
actually get you some pretty dramatic
power savings and we also showed that it
can get you some pretty interesting
performance savings for a given area as
well what Rakesh probably didn't talk
about is that we've also looked at
heterogeneity in the context of a data
center and what these two pictures
represent is again the Apache server
from HP com one of them takes 10 watts
and the other takes hundred watts right
and and if you stare at it enough when
you look at the access this is 500 and
this is 700 so this is obviously the
hundred watt one and this is the 10 watt
one but the point is for a given set of
load maybe if I draw a line somewhere
around here I could very well take my 10
watt system and get the same kind of SLE
guarantees that i would have on my
hundred watt system except that i now
saved a 10x in power and again this has
to do with the power efficiency the MIPS
per watt the inflection point across
various servers and so on and this
picture actually shows the typical
heterogeneity that we are going to find
in any data center and I bet I haven't
done this for Microsoft but I bet
there's going to be most data centers by
of the refresh cycles and so on are
going to have some inherent
heterogeneity and you could use that to
get some pretty dramatic average power
reductions so finally we have a whole
stream of research on what we call
integrated IT facilities resource
management and one of the most
interesting things there is a paper we
published in usenix our last year that
should be using five and this has to do
with the idea of temperature of a lease
or scheduling so if you think about a
typical data center or any any typical
cooled area by virtue of the way you
place your cooling there are going to be
some locations that are going to be
harder and they're going to be some
locations that are cooler and so what we
did in this research was to say can I
match my workloads in a way that the
heart workloads go to the cooler
locations so think of the analogy is you
want to you have two rooms in your house
and you're holding a party and one room
has an air conditioner would you rather
remove all the people to the room but
they are conditioner and turn it down or
are you going to have people in the
second room and blow air all the way
across right and so that's kind of the
analogy here and it turned out that it
sounds like a very straightforward idea
we thought just go change lsf scheduler
or your son grid scheduler or just move
workloads to what we think are the hot
spots it turns out that's the first
algorithm here here is your analog
temperature distribution he want a match
he do that there's an interesting
problem with discretization because
every server can go to one of three
power states and so even though you have
this you have to kind of discretize it
to match that and you get some savings
there but it also turns out that in a
typical data center there are some very
non-intuitive heat flow patterns this
picture shows that so each each line
here is that and what we have here is if
I add a certain amount of heat 1.3 5
kilowatts of heat you notice that two
other rats which are quite far away
increase in temperature by one degrees
and that has to do with how the airflow
mixes the entrainment the
short-circuiting that happens in air
flow and so on so the first algorithm
was basically saying this location is
hot therefore this location is bad and
the second algorithm says this location
is hot therefore I'm not going to put
workloads on that location so there was
some interesting causalities that we had
to factor in but the net net is by being
able to come up with intelligent
algorithms you could say about fifty
percent in energy
so on going back to the Google Data
Center we are talking about again
hundreds of millions of dollars purely
through software optimizations to move
workloads that our energy match that are
cooling matched and obviously this is
this picture here shows that this is
valid only when the data center is not
fully utilized if you have a data center
that's 100% utilize you really have no
choice in how you move this but most
data centers including the Microsoft
data center is used between twenty to
thirty forty percent and so this would
be in this range where you can get some
pretty good savings there ah one of the
nice things with temperature of a
scheduling is you can now think about
this as a reliability play as well so
this picture shows a data center where
this air conditioner has failed and you
see a whole bunch of red spots here
which talk about how many servers done
and in fact in this particular model I
believe that in 90 nano seconds 90
seconds about 180 servers are going to
have thermal failover because of how
this failure model is set up and the
nice thing with temperature of a
scheduling is I can automatically
respond to these in much faster ways
than I can if I had mechanical actuation
and I can move the workloads around an
intelligent ways and between this and
this I believe compared to the hundred
and eighty odd servers that died or this
had only bought PI servers that died and
so essentially you can do temperature
die beste dueling to recover from
failures and on this tyson with the
concept that we've been working on
called smart written and see where you
really don't have to invest in the
optics costs of having multiple air
conditioners multiple redundant
solutions but you can liberate your IT
level solutions to provide smart
residency at the facilities level and
this is again very powerful and
something that a lot of data centers
have benefited from finally there's a
very interesting problem in terms of
some of the work we are doing here and I
call this the intersecting control loop
problem and the problem is fairly
straightforward right and I'm going to
talk about this in the context of power
but we are really solving it at the
whole data center for everything so if
you look at power there is a power
management loop at the processor level
for example foxton that's power
management across multiple course
there's a processor level there's a
power management at the server level
power regulator which is the HP product
does something of the server level
there's something at the enclosure level
powered balancer that we've published in
this car there is something at the
lack and data center level again there's
several solutions that have been talked
about so there's going to be a control
loop at the chip level server level and
closure level data center level there's
going to be a control loop that's going
to be looking at top cooling there's
going to be something that's going to be
looking at power there's something
that's going to be looking at
performance and cooling impacts power
power impacts performance performance
impact schooling there's going to be
something at the operating system level
there's something that's going to be
there the distributor task scheduler
level there's something at the virtual
machine that will be motion talking
about stuff there's going to be
something at the manageability level to
open the you are typically all the kind
of stuff and what ends up happening is
that all of these are kind of looking at
similar objective functions or at least
intersecting objective functions and
they often vary the same knobs but
there's really no coordination between
those and essentially you have chaos in
the data center as all of these
different management optimizers
controllers try to kind of two things
there and so we have actually I had an
intern this summer who has come up with
a very nice solution for this where we
talked about integrator the IT
facilities management where you kind of
provide the it has a whole bunch of buzz
verse here whole estate multi-level
integrator but the point is basically
that you can coordinate all of these
solutions and actually come up with
something that works and we found that
actually heard early results show that
coordinating can actually get you much
more power savings than not coordinating
at much more higher safety guarantees
and finally this is the Burke where we
kind of talks about the taxonomy I am
NOT going to really go into that what I
will point out is that that HP Labs we
spend a lot of time understanding the
fundamental limits I talked about 10x
improvement 100x improvement how much
should we declare victory yard and so
what this is is famous equation for
information transfer it says that
basically if you look at one watt which
is one handheld device you can put about
the computation worth of a billion
Pentiums there so we are obviously no
head close to the theoretical limit so
we have a lot of work to do but a more
pragmatic way to look at it is basically
the energy consumption somebody
mentioned gsm versus 802 11 and so on so
we actually did this experiment where we
time the same exact ask me ron email
application running on the next across a
laptop a handheld a cell phone and a rim
pager so same exact application
one takes 92 million times the handheld
takes 10 times the laptop takes hundred
and sixty times the power so what we
have again is what this is is if I was
running email on a laptop I should be
able to make it at least 100 times more
efficient and what we are doing right
now so we have a gold standard that does
it much better so even if you forget
about the billion Pentiums we still have
much more we should be doing and we can
do and then I have this very nice
interface the definition of taxonomy and
the context for this is basically having
looked at power management all the way
from hand hills to data centers chips to
servers it's pretty much the same set of
fundamental problems and and I kind of
joke that this is your recipe for
improving power in any system that you
have and so I'm not going to go into
more detail you got to read my book to
find out more about it so i click note
on the tools we have a lot of work here
there's something because the while back
on energy monitoring and measurement and
the idea is wouldn't it be really nice
if I could draw a pie charts just like
what G prof does but this pie chart
tells you where you spend your energy
from a software stack and it turns out
is relatively straightforward to do when
it's relatively powerful as well so
that's the first bullet here we have a
paper published on splice and it turns
out when you are trying to correlate
data across the IT and facilities domain
it's a very challenging problem and we
have the very first what we call the
extended knowledge plane that does that
and we have it deployed in our data
center and it's been generating a whole
bunch of insights there finally in
collaboration with several people at
Stanford we've been looking at this
notion of proxy based environmental
metrics so how does the operating system
going to understand how much power is
consumed and we actually have a paper
that's going to come out in the end of
this year where the operating system
purely based on OS level metrics I can
get a power model that is within about
five percent accuracy of an ammeter that
you insert in every server so when you
think about a data center with thought
thousands of servers putting an ammeter
at every server and making sure they're
all synchronized and they all talk to
each other is a pain in the neck but now
if you have things at the operating
system level within five percent
accuracy I can do some very interesting
things and i can now tie it into
controller optimizations which say the
operating system and is doing scheduling
for power it can now evaluate various
there's a whole bunch of stuff there we
are also working on this notion of
benchmarking I talked about our work
with the Department of Energy in terms
of energy about metrics and the initial
initial metric that was very simplest
take that the folks there were
considering was something around MIPS
per watt and very soon it was clear that
that wasn't the right metric and we've
been working with them on several
metrics and in fact HP has a proposal
under review right now called a scale
down efficiency that bills on some of
the work we talked about here but we are
also looking at several different ways
of benchmarking energy comparing
different systems different ecosystems
from an energy efficiency point of view
anyway so I did through a lot of that in
the end but the point again is
irrespective of what you're working on
whether you're working on processors
operating system data centers handhelds
to enterprises so if obvious that energy
is going to become one of the most
important things and poverty is going to
become one of the most important thing
and what we have been doing that HP Labs
said the smart power project is to
systematically address inefficiencies
and I kind of talked about the suite of
solutions we have and the various tools
that we have developed as i mentioned
that even though we've been focused
predominantly unpowered a lot of the
insights the scale much beyond power
into broader resource design management
and monitoring and at the end of the day
powered is one element of the TC home I
mentioned the tech report on tseebo that
we have and and so the whole goal is to
start looking at p.01 cost of ownership
and then when I give my blades plus plus
talk at some point you can see how a lot
of this ties into looking at tseebo and
end-user experience in some very
interesting ways
any any last questions our power
distributed between processor and memory
now processors are also mainly memory
known as cash and if you here to design
for a band for the latch and what did
you do to the cache hierarchy right so
under this tons of academic literature
there and if you look at some of Intel's
roadmap but it is starting to get that
right i mean in fact a lot of our
research is now looking at memory power
as well because the processor power
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit with
these case with better design that we
can get there but at the end of the day
I mean you're just doing more work
you're putting 32 course in a processor
I mean that's why I'd like to put back
famous equation there you want to do
some work you have to burn some energy
right so you're not going to get around
that then it goes back to your question
of is it better to burn that energy
across a distributive system can I have
10 racks in a big blue versus having
templates in a small enclosure and then
it goes back to the manageability space
issues there some absolutely so cash is
very important and and I think it will
get solved in the next year or two at
least the putty total get salt for the
very information on the curve editor
from everyone really fit in prophecy so
again at the end of the day remember
right there's nothing new to engine
power management it will be you have
enough to bring it down so if you look
at ddr2 this I'm very interesting power
states there so we have a paper coming
up that I can send you a free print off
which talks about some code thankfully
nothing runs at me
thankfully diversity has been my saving
grace and in trying to keep legible
right because people put in a bot the
nameplate of 300 Watson and throws 100
so there's this over-provisioning it
keeps going on and I'm not sure they
give you an example of efficiencies of
motive at you know we have groups are
investing in trackables because they
wanted the super high density and but
what it's excited said well okay what's
Iraq when I research on our side one
things they do is they match the power
supply to the actual demand that a box
is going to see and it's just that the
box is what it is and you know most
civilians site the power supply on a
server box too okay what's the most
somebody could possibly stick inside
this box as the end up with a power
supply at 500 watts on a machine that's
going to draw hunters it's an example of
how power supply efficiency me help so
on a single sided rack of rack it draws
6kw on there to side iraq iraq they put
in a single large DC power supply that
feeds all the sir it draws 12 which you
chose 10 so instead of me double sitting
away from six to 12 goes from six to ten
when you file line there's like a lot of
low-hanging fruit in the area of a power
supply design
now even without getting into the
software management piece just enhance
that fair enough and there's tons of
work there if you look at the power
supply efficiencies over the past let's
say five years efficiencies have gone a
pretty dramatically in fact the Energy
Star rating they started off saying the
way the first thing given and
legislators to look at publish supply
efficiencies and given instance that
every server comes with a power supply
efficiency that's over a certain range
and very soon they found out that people
have improved the heck out with that so
the little but but there is definitely
low-hanging fruit and I think most of
the road maps account for that what is
interesting is tying that in dynamically
to the load because again there is an
efficiency curve and you have two
options one is to make the efficiency
curve stretch it out so that is more
efficient and that from what I
understand from the power supply guys is
a very hard problem and so we've looked
at some interesting based there so we
have some intellectual property that
captures that so so I guess your point
is well-taken there is low-hanging fruit
and power supplies I think some of that
low hanging fruit will be harvested in
the next year or two there is going to
be other stuff and there are going to be
other business reasons for why that's
not done I want to thank you in your
research when you're working on the
reducing power for display do you ever
look at the research that's going on
with regards to fathering the area
that's out of focus and for example
turning off pixels randomly in the area
it's not in the focus yeah we did do
that i mean the optimizations i showed
you what where we dimmed every pixel and
then we actually cuts it on where we say
we kind of dim every thirteenth pixel
and then randomly change it and hope
nobody really notices and it turns out
people notice because people's
peripheral elevations are tuned to all
these subconscious things so and as I
said I mean you could kind of dim
everything in a fairly honest face and
still get all the benefits and still
have the users say that they like the
interface so we didn't go down that path
but we actually have a bunch of
algorithms in the patient's about this
approach which talk about doing some of
those things
we didn't look at it in great detail but
the few things we did even I could
notice it and my first rule of thumb is
I need to enjoy my interface first
before I even ship it on somebody else
right and so so we really didn't go down
that path brother he had i think in one
of our experiments we had one interface
where we looked at that and the kodak
guys were very interested in this
because with all that players value in
doing this because of the lifetime for a
bunch of reasons but so like I said the
straight answer has really didn't spend
too much time thinking about it because
it didn't seem worthwhile to go down the
direction
sounds good let's not be left to class
but